this animation is brought to you by the
nucleus medical art library or enmol
where you can download this animation
and thousands of medical images and
videos created by nucleus medical media
to apply for a free 30-day trial click
on the link in the description
if a man has trouble getting a woman
pregnant he may have a condition known
as infertility
his doctor may recommend a procedure to
collect his sperm so it can be used to
help him father a child
the male reproductive system includes
the testicles also known as testes which
are two glands in a pouch of skin called
the scrotum
the testicles normally produce and store
reproductive cells called sperm
the scrotum is outside the body which
keeps the testicles cool enough to make
sperm
connected to each testicle is a mass of
coiled tubes called the epididymis
each epididymis stores immature sperm
while they continue to develop
during sex sperm travel through a tube
attached to the epididymis called the
vas deferens
to another tube called the ejaculatory
duct
there sperm mix with fluid from two
glands called seminal vesicles
as well as the prostate gland
now called semen this fluid mixture
exits the man's body through the urethra
the tube inside the penis that usually
carries urine
if a man has sex with a woman this
process called ejaculation deposits
semen in her vagina
semen contain tens of millions of sperm
from the vagina the sperm in the semen
can travel to and fertilize an egg from
the woman's body
fertilization of the egg marks the
beginning of human development during
pregnancy
sperm retrieval and collection are
usually performed for a condition called
azoaspermia where a man has no
measurable amounts of sperm in his semen
there are two types of azoaspermia
the first type called obstructive
azoaspermia occurs when the pathway of
sperm out of the body is blocked
the second type of asospermia called
non-obstructive asospermia occurs when
the testicles produce little or no sperm
there are several procedures to remove
fluid from a testicle or an epididymis
to see if it contains healthy sperm
during percutaneous procedures sperm are
removed through the skin of the scrotum
without making an incision
for example during a percutaneous
epididymal sperm aspiration or pisa the
surgeon will insert a syringe into the
epididymis through the skin
fluid from inside the epididymis will be
drawn into the syringe
or during a testicular sperm aspiration
or tisa the doctor will insert a syringe
into the testicle through the skin
fluid from inside the testicle will be
drawn into the syringe
if the fluid contains sperm it can be
saved for a later procedure to fertilize
an egg
if the fluid retrieved through a
percutaneous procedure doesn't contain
any sperm
an open sperm retrieval procedure may be
done to find other areas in the
epididymis or testicle more likely to
contain sperm
in any of the open procedures the
surgeon will begin by making an incision
in the scrotum
the testicle and epididymis will be
pulled through the skin incision and
another incision will be made in the
outer tissue covering the epididymis and
testicle
during an open fine needle aspiration
the surgeon will insert a needle into
several areas of the epididymis
each time the needle is inserted fluid
will be removed
during a micro
epididymal sperm aspiration or mesa
the surgeon will use an operating
microscope to get a magnified view of
the epididymis
the surgeon will make a tiny incision in
the thin tissue covering the epididymis
to reveal the coiled tubes inside
then a tiny hollow tube called a
micropipette will be used to puncture
one or more of the coiled tubes and
remove fluid from inside it
after removing the fluid the tissue
covering the epididymis will be closed
with sutures
another open procedure is called
microsurgical testicular sperm
extraction or micro tessie
in this procedure the surgeon will make
a small incision in the tissue covering
the testicle instead of the epididymis
next the surgeon will use an operating
microscope to look at the tiny tubes
inside the testicle
a tissue sample of the tubes most likely
to contain healthy sperm will be removed
the sample will be examined under a
microscope to see if it contains healthy
sperm
if no sperm are found more samples will
be removed and examined
once sperm are found the tissue sample
will be stored for later use
then the tissue covering the testicle
will be closed with sutures
after all of these open procedures the
surgeon will close the tissue covering
the epididymis and testicle with sutures
finally the skin incision in the scrotum
will also be closed with sutures
the collected sperm will allow a man to
father a child through intracytoplasmic
sperm injection
during this procedure a sperm cell will
be injected directly into a woman's egg
to fertilize it
if the collected sperm are not used
right away they can be frozen for use at
a later date